it's so good to see you how have you
been how's how's everything going what
can you tell us what can you tell us yes
i've been great i've been filming the
color purple i'm supposed to be wrapped
this next week so crossing my fingers we
get it done just having a great time how
has it been i mean we want details all
everybody wants details oh my gosh i
pinch myself every day on that set
because you know to be a part of such a
historic film that we all have known
growing up it's like wow what can we do
to make this even greater than it
already is because it's such an amazing
base and i'm just grateful to be a part
of the whole project
okay i want to ask you about
beyonce's new album have you heard it
have you had a chance to hear this i
can't tell you that
but
she's amazing it's amazing she is just
wow break my soul is amazing it's
amazing and how does she always seem to
find the pulse what is it about her it's
because she's beyonce i mean
it is what it is at this point everyone
can't deny the greatness
there's no deny
what is it to work
in the tutelage of someone who is so
great is that extra pressure because
when people look at you they think her
yes you know i i truly think it's a
blessing honestly to kind of be
associated with somebody who is just
that powerful in her presence
and you know who has influenced so many
of us especially me and to even be a
part of the conversation of following
her footsteps is an honor so i'm just
grateful to even know her really and how
weird has it been for you and your
sister be apart your sister working you
working how how weird has that been yes
it's been crazy but it's been amazing
because you know like every time i need
my sister i just call her up she's right
there especially tonight which is her
night this performance oh my god your
mind is going to be blown tell me what
can you tell me i can just tell you
you're prepare to be amazed
it is a show honey okay
prepare to be entertained all right
that's all i'll say all right anything
you can tell us about what have you
heard about little mermaid
well
i've seen little clips
in adr and i just i cried the other day
when i was in adr because i'm like i
don't understand how this is happening
how this is me and i'm just it's very
overwhelming and i get really emotional
when talking about it
[Music]
you